bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors le liban est donc
doté d'un nouveau premier ministre
moustapha adib que vous inspire cette
nomination est ce qu'il peut être
l'homme de la situation pour sortir le
pays de la crise économique et sanitaire
bon tu as fait c'est une bonne nouvelle
il y avait eu déjà deux bonnes nouvelles
hier lorsque comme vous l'avez dit le
président de la république michel aoun
avait fait un discours à la télévision
pour indiquer que maintenant il fallait
faire les réformes qu'il fallait passer
aux réformes structurelles et il avait
même été jusqu'à dire ce qui est très
surprenant au liban qu'il était temps
d'établir un état laïc
il a confirmé d'ailleurs ses
déclarations dans une chronique ce matin
au journal le figaro
bien sûr il ne chronique qui précède
l'arrivée du premier du prêteur la
république français emmanuel macron et
puis hier aussi
le chef du hezbollah monsieur nasrallah
a fait une déclaration beaucoup plus
surprenante encore disant qu'il était
prêt à discuter dans un esprit ouvert un
nouveau pacte politique au liban
par conséquent le climat est tout à fait
particulier et puisque le premier
ministre devait être comme vous l'avez
dit également un sunnite et bien tous
les anciens premiers ministres vivants
qui sont des sunnites se sont réunis et
ont désigné l'actuel ambassadeur du
liban à berlin depuis d'ailleurs s'étend
donc depuis très longtemps mais qui a un
petit passé politique puisqu'il a été
aussi directeur de cabinet à un moment
donné d'un premier ministre libanais
c'est d'un universitaire qui est un
professeur de droit de sciences
politiques à l'université d'une bande
qui à 48 ans et qui par conséquent a les
cartes en main le premier test qui
auquel il va être soumis
c'est évidemment la constitution de son
gouvernement ou bien il arrive à
constituer un gouvernement
en effet de gens compétents probablement
de technocrates un gouvernement de
transition pour amorcer les réformes et
pour surtout préparer de nouvelles
élections ou bien il n'y arrive pas et
il reproduit le schéma habituel
c'est-à-dire
le partage des différents ministères en
fonction de l'intérêt qu'il présente
notamment un point de vue financier
alors on va voir lorsqu'il présentera
son gouvernement
quels sont les membres de ce
gouvernement et s'ils sont les
représentants fidèle des factions
antérieures qui ont mené le liban à la
ruine ou bien si effectivement c'est une
équipe resserrée et compétente qui peut
mener la réforme
ça va être son premier défi le deuxième
défi l'a d'ailleurs dit aujourd'hui
dans sa déclaration introductive eh bien
c'est la négociation avec le fmi le
liban est un pays failli le divan ne
peut plus payer ses dettes
et évidemment il a besoin du fmi
simplement le fmi qui a vu dans le passé
ces crédits un peu s'évaporait à
disparaître dans la structure politique
libanaise pose ses conditions
et ces conditions sont exactement les
mêmes que tout le sel de tous les
interlocuteurs du liban l'union
européenne la france et d'autre il faut
faire des réformes structurelles
notamment dans le domaine de l'énergie
et notamment de l'électricité mais aussi
dans le domaine des télécommunications
il faut faire un audit complet de la
banque centrale réformer le système
bancaire et introduire une transparence
des opérations dans le domaine
gouvernementales et dans le domaine des
agences publiques autrement dit
éradiquer la corruption
emmanuel macron se déplace au liban il
sera d'ici quelques heures maintenant
quel est l'objet de cette visite le
président français lui s'est très vite
mobilisés à des routes après la double
explosion dans le port de la capitale à
quoi doit-on s'attendre il est arrivé
donc on oublie deux jours après
l'explosion ce qui est quand même très
rapide il avait promis de revenir et
d'être là le 1er septembre il laissera
le 1er septembre cette promesse et cette
confirmation de sa venue a déjà eu un
effet nous venons d'en parler avec la
nomination de ce premier ministre
réformateur réformateur entre guillemets
pour le moment et il va consulter toutes
les forces politiques après s'être
entretenu avec le président de la
république monsieur michel ayoun et
aussi avec bien sûr le président du
parlement
qui est président du parlement depuis 28
ans monsieur nabih berry et donc il va
effectivement à nouveau leur dire c'est
à vous que le meut l'avenir du liban
appartient il faut que vous créer les
conditions d'une réforme de réformes
structurelles au liban sinon personne ne
fera crédit à ce pays et ne l'aidera à
se redresser alors que même avant cela
ce soir je crois qu'il va voir un
personnage mythique une icône du liban
qui est la chanteuse fair use et fair
use en effet c'est dans le fond une très
grande vedette sur la sur la scène
libanaise depuis très longtemps est
l'incarnation de l'unité de la nation
libanaise
donc c'est un peu un symbole demain il
ira aussi sur le port là où il ya des
ong qui travaillent il ya aussi 400
militaires français qui avec les
militaires libanais déblais chaque jour
une tonne de matériel de destruction qui
ont été des de ce qui a été détruit par
l'explosion et il s'entretiendra aussi
avec la population comme il l'a fait il
ya un peu plus de trois semaines
il y avait cette scène tout à fait
étonnante où il été pris à partie par
une jeune femme libanaise qui disait oui
vous voulez vous parler et puis après on
passera à autre chose il a dit non je
reviendrai le 1er septembre et vous
verrez que nous nous allons nous allons
progresser alors peut-être la retrouvera
t-il en tout cas il retrouvera d'autres
personnages de la société civile qui lui
demanderont quelle est la prochaine
étape plate blanchemaison merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes expert en relations
internationales